a new survey found that lawyer is
considered lawyer is considered the most
sexy profession to list on dating apps
and they Conan yeah what can i what can
I do for you sir oh that's right sir are
you are you okay yeah I just interrupted
you so now where's where's the funny
thing I'm sorry I have no idea what you
mean but I just i watch this show all
the time and usually when someone yells
out hey Conan and interrupts you a bunch
of funny stuff happens around them so
where is that no sir that's because we
plan those things in advance we use
hired actors you can't just come to the
show and interrupt and then just expect
something funny to happen oh okay unless
you have something funny you'd like to
add oh definitely yeah here goes cool so
do you ever watch The Good Wife yeah
couple of episodes I've watched The Good
Wife episode great
what
he's just so hard
[Applause]
something with hashtag you could be
whatever you asked to change your seat
like what if you have one small hand in
one big hand
yeah well this is help it's a man
yelling surrounded by pizza maybe you
ate something that gave you a funny
accent so you're like all right
Kevin I don't know what's wrong with me
what if Gilligan builds a time machine
out of coconut that's been done all
right you have a choice of signs
macaroni salad coleslaw and potato salad
or a bag of chips what if when you open
your mouth instead of your regular voice
it's just a dull singing ladies and
gentlemen I'm really sorry about that
interruption but don't worry we do have
a great show tonight we'll have a treat
Conan oh hey you got something now yeah
I think you mean we have a grape show
welcome to show business good
congratulations thank you that was the
day I became the funniest guy in the
world
[Applause]
well no other show will do that hey we
got a good one tonight
you